to answer your questions I've asked you
two questions should a mass stay in
power and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonado appear morg uncensored the NHS
suspends a GP who was Moonlighting as a
leader of a terrorist movement that's
now banned in Britain should he keep his
job we'll debate that Prince Harry is
slammed for parting with a reality TV
star who's accused of exploiting dubious
Royal connections for financial gain
Prince or he calls himself that Mario
Max joins me live and Barbie's girls are
are snubbed at the Oscars as both Margo
Robbie and Greta Gerwig miss out but
Ryan Gosling gets a nod for playing Ken
a win for the
[Music]
patriarchy live from the news building
in London this is Pierce Morgan
uncensored good evening for L welcome to
peer Morgan un sensor Dr Abdul wahed is
the public face and British leader of a
controversial islamist movement which
glorified the Hamas attacks and chanted
for Jihad on the Streets of London is
also a longtime NHS GP doctor at least
for now today the NHS in London
confirmed his suspended Dr wahed after
his controversial appearance on this
show and the newspaper reports about him
referring to the doctor by legal name a
spokesman told us this morning we take
any issues relating to professional
conduct seriously and have procedures in
place to make sure that individuals are
fit to work in the NHS we can confirm
that Dr wahed shaa sha has been
suspended from NHS Primary Care
performance list well last month uh Dr
wahed under his other name was brave
enough to appear on uncensored Brave you
can judge for yourself how it went 1200
people were massacred were they I think
1200 people were killed were they
massacred yeah they were killed by
terrorists they were killed by people
who were resisting an occupation and
they're terrorists yeah well that's your
view it is my view one man's terrorist
is a n man's Freedom Fighter have you
never heard that well many people who
saw that interview was shocked by
someone who cast down where the October
7th attacks had even taken place let
alone not considering Hamas to be
terrorists after it dismissing any
civilian deaths as collateral and active
resistance could remain working in the
National Health Service with a salary
paid by the British taxpayer but at the
same time it was reasonable to debate
whether radical opinions have any real
bearing on someone's ability to practice
medicine after all people have opinion
very right to opinions that others find
offensive that is why he was invited on
the show in the first place but Dr wahed
is now effectively the head of a
prescribed terror group and it's
prescribed as terror group not just here
in the UK now but in numerous other
countries too and there is no defense
for that hisb teria is a global islamist
movement which advocates for an Islamic
caliphate under Sharia law in this
country they made headlines for
denouncing LGBT filth as they put it and
calling for an end to the Western World
Order it's outlawed in plenty of other
countries like Germany Egypt several
Arab states last week the British
Parliament officially designed it as a
terrorist organization that means
membership or support for hisb but terer
is now illegal carrying a prison
sentence of up to 14 years now to be
clear I've not called for Dr wahi to be
suspended fired or cancelled but I did
question whether his views made him fit
to serve patients many of whom by his
own admission don't even know about his
double life because he uses two separate
names now he is the head of an
officially prescribed terrorist
organization and the whole argument
becomes a lot simpler it is frankly
untenable for him to be working in the
NHS and if he wants any hope of
continuing those duties he needs to
start doing something he repeatedly
failed to do on the show last time
distance himself publicly from
terrorists and
terrorism well joining me now is the
author podcast po comedian Constantine
kissy constan great to see you um what
do you make up this story quite
extraordinary that for decades this guy
had been operating in North London as a
GP and yet in his other uh vocation he
was leading the UK arm of a group that
was already uh considered a terror group
by many other countries and is now uh
also considered that way in this
country right and you should put some we
should put some meet on the bones of
that because you mentioned that the
group has banned in Egypt Germany and a
few other countries actually PE as you
probably know the group is banned in
almost every Muslim country in the world
Indonesia the most populous Muslim
country in the world has banned hisb
Tera Pakistan Bangladesh almost every
Arab country in the Middle East has
banned hisb Tera so the question I think
we really ought to be asking is why did
the British government allow these
islamists to operate in Britain for as
long as they did now coming to your
point about whether he should be
suspended from the NHS as you know I
think both you and I are very wary of
people being uh banned or censored in
some way for for the opinions that they
express but I think most British people
would draw the line at being a member or
indeed the head of a now prescribed
terrorist organization and of course we
also got to remember there is a
difference between a guy stacking
shelves in the supermarket and someone
who is a GP who would be seeing patients
know intimate details about them know
their ethnicity religion and have the
power of in some situations life and
death over people so I think it's it's a
very different case and I've got
absolutely no problem with terrorist
sympathizers being prevented from
working in the National Health Service
right and to to be you know to be clear
about what his views were post October
7th he gave a talk on YouTube uh and he
said
this they gave the enemy a punch on the
nose all right and and it's a very
welcome punch on the
nose welcome punch on the nose which is
1,200 people including at least 800
innocent civilians including many
children women being brutally murdered
raped in some cases beheaded that was
apparently a very welcome punch on the
most says an NHS doctor whose salary is
paid by the British taxpayer I mean I
think for that
alone unless he renounces what he said
there very clearly and firmly there
could be no way back for
him well quite and I think you know if
he were to renounce I think we'd all
question how legitimate and how sincere
that renunciation would be given his uh
body of work let's say on on this issue
I think there are some people who've
been tolerated for far too long in our
country and uh members of hisb terer
which is now thankfully prescribed uh if
they're not citizens of this country I
think the British people will be asking
why are they still here yeah because we
had uh in October the same uh wahed
addressing a rally outside the Egyptian
and Turkish embassies in London during
which he told the crowd Victory is
coming everyone has to choose a side
another senior member mazia Khan of the
same now terror group said what is the
solution to liberate people in the
concentration camp called Palestine and
they chanted back Jihad jih had G we got
a clip of this what is the solution to
liberate people in the concentration
camp from Palestine what is the
solution I mean you know we there's been
lots of debate about the pro Palestinian
marches I'm going to come to some
fascinating footage that you've done for
a film about those um and you know many
people are there legitimately Marching
for peace I completely get that but when
you have people on the Streets of London
chanting Jihad Jihad Jihad that is
unacceptable and you will remember PE
that the the Met police shamefully uh
instead of dealing with those people
under the law of this country instead
what they did is they said well Jihad
has many meanings and essentially
protect tended not to understand what
those people were calling for um but as
you say people have a right to protest
people should speak freely and express
themselves and by the way uh I think
actually you know you and I both take a
lot of flaque for so-called platforming
people with the wrong opinions I
actually think this is a very good
example of a situation in which allowing
people to speak freely and express their
horrific opinions in public is a a a
thing a method that allows uh them to
express those opinions and then for the
public frankly to take a position on
whether those people should be serving
them in the Public Health Service should
be in our country if they're not
citizens of this country and I actually
think you've done a very good job Piers
of bringing these people into the light
and letting them hang themselves with
their own rope yeah I mean people said
you exposed him uh and you've got him
suspended no he exposed himself by
expressing very firmly his own views
which were supportive of Hass which is a
prescribed terror group in this country
so that was in itself illegal actually
what he was doing and now he is the head
of an organization that's just been
designated as a terror group and that is
also illegal so there's a lot of crime
being committed here by this NHS doctor
never mind anything else uh I didn't
expose that he was doing it himself I
want to bring in now the columnist and
commentator vaj Ali vaj thank you very
much indeed for joining me um what do
you make of the story for having me this
this guy is an NHS doctor for many
decades I'm sure there'll be plenty of
his patients who'd say he's a perfectly
good doctor doctor what's he got to do
with that that he has these views but
now the UK government has prescribed the
organization that he runs in the UK as a
terrorist organization is his position
as a doctor here
untenable well listen the show is called
uncensored and I think all of us agree
that in a free Society we should have
something what we have in America the
First Amendment freedom of worship free
speech freedom of assembly and
unfortunately there are elements
extremist elements within our society
that we tolerate that doesn't mean that
we agree with them that doesn't mean
that we support them that doesn't mean
we endorse them like I'll give you an
example hisb areer has been an annoyance
an annoyance in my life they're here in
America they're all around they have
these aspirational dreams of a caliphate
that will never happen and some of them
have very hateful views right they do
not like me at all in this particular
situation though you have to realize
that several British governments have
tried to commit uh his the as a terror
organization this is not the first right
but they haven't found any actionable
threats in this particular climate in
the past 3 months as you know you had
your former Home Secretary Suella
Braverman not really uh a fan uh uh of I
would say Muslim or Muslim immigrants
who during these protests where a bunch
of these nuts uh sparsely populated
protest yelled the word Jihad and
apparently praised Hamas she wanted to
expose them right she said look into it
and then now in the past two weeks you
finally have exposed them as a terror
group Co unquote terror group but there
are zero actionable Terror threats so
what happens in this situation it
reminds me Pierce as an American of a
post 911 climate where he had 19 foreign
Muslim hijackers who brought down the
two towers and the country lost its mind
and use that as a giant net to go after
a bunch of Muslims we did a registry
program we uh deported 13,000 immigrants
we literally had the NYPD peers in this
country surveil Muslim mosques Muslim
Students Muslim grocery stores right
anyone who said the wrong word people
were kicked off of planes for saying
Arabic words so I'm sitting here and I'm
I'm listening to your conversation and I
think you did the right thing these nuts
Who exist right you expose them you
marginalize them you bring them on and
then they go into the fringes of society
in America we have the KKK in America if
you look at this there's a capital right
behind me there are people who did a
violent Insurrection against the United
States in that Capital we have elected
officials in America who call those
people political prisoners and martyrs
they're elected uh people who incited
violence against our law enforcement so
I think the the what you what I hope
you're not doing and I I feel like
you're doing is this giant net this
giant hammer to crush them I think it
will not make things better in in Great
Britain and in Europe and I think it
will give Fuel and fod to extremists on
both sides the right-wing uh militant
nationalists the white nationalists who
attacked the police after Home Secretary
braverman's article you remember that
and also these Fringe elements I think
it will further radicalize them I don't
think this is what you do in a free
Society but that's just me speaking on
your show called un well you know what
it's an unsensored show and you rais
some very interesting and valid points
constanty what's your reaction to What
Vadar said there well my re my reaction
is I I encourage all our viewers to go
and uh watch an interview with the UA
foreign minister given in 2017 in which
he warned Western governments that their
obsession with uh political correctness
his words not mine and being unwilling
to deal with Islamic extremism in the
way that it should be dealt with
will lead to more terrorism and more
violent crime in their countries and
that interview has gone super viral on
the internet precisely because of how
prophetic it was uh if as I said earlier
almost every Muslim country in the world
considers these people to be Islamic
extremists who are to be banned I think
we should be learning from them uh on
how to deal with these people instead of
thinking that we in our liberal Society
are able to integrate all these people
these people do not belong in this
country and they views do not belong in
this country and as I say if they're not
citizens of this country they should not
be here yeah you know it's interesting I
when I walk around now because there's
been loads of memes about me because of
all the big interviews we've done and it
always has me dressed up as some
reporter saying do you condemn Hamas to
inappropriate people all the time and I
get asked in the street now do you
condemn Hass like it's a joke and I said
you know I always reply to people you
know you have to start with that
question do you condemn what Hamas did
on October the 7th and do you accept
it's a terrorist attack
because if you can't accept that badad
to me if you can't accept that basic
fact which we saw not because people
invented those uh those monstrosities
they committed but because they openly
brazenly broadcast them to the world
through their own technology to because
they were proud of what they were
committing I don't think if if you don't
start from a position that you condemn
what Hamas did I don't really have much
time for
you then why are you in a democracy why
do you claim to be an enlightened
government why are you any different
from authoritarian Muslim countries that
crack down on any grp any group they
don't like there's a reason why we have
the First Amendment there's a reason why
you have a freedom uh of assembly of
Association of a free speech because
like Vol said I don't agree with what
you said about defend to the death your
right to say it that doesn't mean you
like them I'll give you an example
United States we have the KKK an actual
terrorist group that committed terrorism
against black and white Americans they
still exist they have the right to
assembly they do their stupid marches
like cowards they put on their masks I
don't know you saw that viral video it
went viral that a bunch of them wearing
white masks in New York got stuck at a
Turn Style because they didn't know how
to use uh the New York subway station
just Exquisite it was like a melbrook
scene but they exist we had literally
people saying the Jews will not replace
us and Donald Trump said they're very
fine people we literally have people
like I said going against this Capital
right here committing a violent
Insurrection but for some strange reason
when the number one domestic Terror
threat in America and also increasingly
in Europe and the UK is white terrorists
white nationalist terrorists white
extremists I never hear anyone say you
know what we should ban them we should
Deport them oh what I instead hear is
they have economic anxiety the double
standard here at play has to be exposed
right and I want people to really think
about what they're really advocating if
someone doesn't like your speech you
know what you're not just going to be uh
not tolerated you're going to be
deported especially if you're a person
of color how does that make a
multi-racial society that is both the UK
and America safer and better especially
and I'm speaking now as an American and
you know in the UK the rising domestic
Terror threat is not Islamic extremism
which by the way exists it is white
nationalist extremism not a single word
about that but I hear all these Free
Speech Advocates all these people are
all about Western Civilization all all
of a sudden turn to censorship and all
of a sudden become authoritarian when it
comes to Muslims and people of hang on
why is that hang let me educate your
guest a little bit about his own country
country
pleas I I'm about to be quiet and I will
now first of all nobody's calling for
people to be deported because of their
views we have laws in this country
against organizations that are
prescribed as terrorists and I have no
problem with terrorists being removed
from this country under the laws of this
country secondly Donald Trump never said
that the people calling uh for the
eradication of Jews will find people if
you go and look at his quotes he
actually condemned them and said they
should be condemned absolutely but the
people who were there protesting about
the statues they were the ones that
would fine people now you should educate
yourself about those things and thirdly
you should educate about the fact that
regrettably I would quite like to have a
First Amendment here in the UK we do not
have a First Amendment and I would have
a lot more sympathy with your argument
if we hadn't spent the last 10 years
watching people be sacked from their
jobs for saying women are women and men
are men yeah and I would also add that
when you say that I'm not respecting
free speech V when I say I don't respect
people who won't condemn for Mass
they're I didn't say you no no but they
can say it they can say it I just don't
have to respect it it's a bit like when
I block people on Twitter you don't have
to respect it but when I when I block
people on on X for example formerly
Twitter and people say well you're
suppressing their free speech no I'm not
they can still tweet what the hell they
like I just don't have to read it I
don't have to hear it you know that this
that actually is what free speech is and
the First Amendment which is one of the
most powerful Protectors of free speech
in the world it doesn't cover many
things from child pornography to
defamation to all sorts of stuff is is
not protected by the First Amendment and
nobody I don't think who looks at this
sensibly would say that a terror group
that espouses not just hatred but
violent hatred and the mass killing of
people that is never protected by free
speech is it and should it be uh it it
shouldn't be but listen this is
interesting uh speaking about education
allow me to retort and educate and I'll
give you an example about the double
standards and I want you guys to really
respond to this speaking about terrorism
and violence on the platform you
mentioned X also known as Twitter one of
the wealthiest men Elon Musk has
repeatedly promoted the replacement
Theory an anti-semitic Terror uh anti
anti-semitic conspiracy that blames Jews
for trying to weaken and replace Western
Civilization with Muslims and immigrants
and lgbtq communities right that
conspiracy theory has radicalized
individuals to commit violence against
Jews against Muslims against black
people against Latinos that conspiracy
has been retweeted and platformed and
mainstreamed by the Republican party
people like Elise stonic and Donald
Trump who by the way dined with Nick
Fuentes the leading white nationalist
leader in America you guys are fine with
that when it comes to any other group
that say who said we're fine wait a
minute who
said okay colum can it what are you
talking about good but you're not going
to deport them right are you going to
deport them are you going to are you
going to call them out
forpac people who are citizens who are
not citizens of the country should be
deported if they're members of a
terrorist group why don't you understand
the distinction member of a terrorist
group government saying something WR
should us and UK should us and UK
government and National Security go
after these groups and these elected
officials and these organizations that
have literally repeated and mainstreamed
a conspiracy that has motivated
terrorists to commit
terrorism anyone who is a member of a
terrorist group should be prosecuted
under the law of the country in which
they are a terrorist group of a
terrorist gr that's not what I asked
well but that's what I said so you were
challenging me about something I and I'm
very curious people why you are not
concerned about this but in this in I
didn't say I wasn't concerned about it I
said you can't Deport citizens of the
country in which they live a and B I
keep pointing out to you that the person
we're talking about in this case this
NHS GP he is a member of a terrorist
group we're not talking about him having
the wrong opinions people are allowed to
have the wrong opinions both in this
country and in your country it's
something that we all celebrate as part
of the heritage of Western civilization
and we would all I hope defend the issue
here is we have laws in this country
about being a member of a terrorist
group and people who are members of a
terrorist group I hope you would agree
with me should be prosecuted to the full
extent of the law and if they are
prosecuted to the extent of the law and
they are foreign citizens should be
deported will we agree on
that we will agree that and I'll also
say this uh for those who are watching
especially the youth uh there's a great
meme a family guy meme where there's a
chart of who gets to be labeled a
terrorist and who doesn't uh the front
part of the chart is when you have light
skinn you're not a terrorist when it
gets dark and people like you always
bring race into it it's got nothing to
do with race everything to do with
people who kill
people yes people like you race ba like
yes and I've not heard you really
Express this much outrage against the
number one domestic Terror threat
against all our communities in America
and the UK which is rising white
National a dark first generation
immigrant to the UK I don't play your
racial games stop using your skin color
as a way to shut other people up and
let's talk about the issue the issue
here is should we tolerate foreign
terrorist should we remove them and my
opinion is we should remove people who
are not conducive to this country and if
someone like me first generation
immigrant comes here and wants to be a
terrorist it is first generation
immigrants like me that are at the front
of the queue to get them out okay it's
been a fascinating debate remove people
not conducive to the it's been it's been
a fasc debate I actually think who are
terrorists yes I actually think that to
be fair to you I do think that the white
nationalism related terrorist acts that
we see increasingly is never played up
as much actually as islamist Terror was
particularly in the Heyday of al-Qaeda
and Isis I think it's a perfectly valid
point to make for what it's worth I
think I've made that point actually
before um Before I Let You Go Constantin
you've done a lot of filming with the
pro Palestinian marches in London what
did you
find well I actually went over the last
few months per we went to the protest
against anti-Semitism we went to two pro
Palestine protests we went to an
Extinction rebellious Rebellion protest
which was very very funny I encourage
people to go and watch that but at the
latest Pro Palestine protest in
particular there was some fascinating
scenes and you know we really tried to
talk to people with an open mind I don't
have actually contrary to the discussion
we've just had a particularly strong uh
position on I'm interested really in
getting people's views and one of the
things that came through very strongly
is
uh young people in particular of whom
there are many the way I would kind of
describe the demographics are it's a
mixture of sort of beards and head
scarves on the one hand and septum
piercings and colored hair on the other
um the young people who are there in
particular when you are some very very
basic questions you know from which
river to well let's take a look at a
clip actually we've got a we've got a
clip with some of this let's watch it
here so I just noticed the signs you got
from The River To The Sea Palestine will
be free what does that mean well it's
quite self expan how would that come
about what would happen to the Israelis
Etc I
don't I'm trying to think of how to word
it isn't it just as self-explanatory as
the area of land it's palestine's land
what's a socialist in if I'm being
honest with you I just got this at the
stand over there okay uh I don't
actually know the definition of the word
it I mean it's kind of laughable I don't
think for a moment that a lot of people
on that March are that ignorant about it
a lot of them clearly are well informed
and absolutely marching because they
want peace and they want to cease fire
in Gaza I completely understand that but
vajat when you hear that there are a lot
of young people joining up in these
marches who are completely clueless and
I actually blame Tik Tock more than
anything which is the number one news
source now for kids under 25 and spew
just Relentless nonsense into their
heads and that's where they get their
news
uh this is where I'm going to stand up
for the Youth if you look at the youth
it's been a stunning change where most
youth people uh youth here and abroad
are actually if you will Pro Palestinian
and want the occupation to end and the
flip side to that pierce I would say is
the following for those who are watching
we're the same when it comes to Facebook
we're the same when it comes to X and
we're the same when it comes to
mainstream media you are a breath of
fresh air because you allow multiple
opinions to come on uh you know talk
about Palestinian side and Israeli side
in America you know that this wasn't the
case and so for those people who are
terrified by the Tik Tok just think
about what limited viewpoints that you
got for 30 40 years and now for better
and for worse this young generation is
exposed to multiple narratives and they
see for themselves what's happening
which is why you see the shift in which
a lot of people especially in Israel and
here are horrified by the N Yahoo
government want an end to the occupation
want to ceas fire hate Hamas hat hate
extremists in the N Yahoo government and
believe that Palestinians have a right
to Freedom yeah well they certainly do
in my estimation but there is one clip
uh Constantine which really got to me it
was about me let's take a look so I see
you've got a sign that say journalism
that get paid for selling lies and I'm
guessing that's Pierce Morgan right why
do you say that this is journalism
that's selling
lies um it's very obvious what is going
on all the lies about what happened on
the October 7th the justification for
the genocide they're all based on Lies
when you say lies about October oober
7th what do you mean all those
allegations that we never saw any
footages of of decapitated children that
Piers Morgan always asked about and all
those women that get got uh gang raped I
mean it was quite extraordinary
Constantine because one of the problems
with platforming everybody actually for
the last three months is you end up with
the extremes on both sides hating you
with equal Vengeance and often being
completely ill-informed actually about
what I've actually said um but it was
enlightening to see that because I see
that all day long on social media that
kind of view which is really based on a
lack of
reality well there was a lot of that
going on in the protest and
interestingly I mean you say most people
there are well informed uh we released
in that half an hour documentary that
people can go to trigonometry our
YouTube channel and watch we released
every single interview that we did uh so
we haven't cherry-picked these moments
to make people look bad or anything like
that it contains they're shortened down
but they are basically the content of
what people said to us okay and I have
to say most of the people we spoke to a
didn't really seem that actually that
well informed most of them and secondly
I would say that was an awful lot of the
sort of thing you just heard where
people have some kind of way of
pretending October 7th didn't happen in
fact the first person you see in the
video talks about how it's a false flag
operation there seems to be a lot of
that going on too where where people are
sort of they they sort of wish away the
terrorist attack on October 7th and it
makes sense because if you're calling
for a ceasefire uh and you're calling on
Israel to unilaterally essentially
engage in the ceasefire you have to
pretend October 7th didn't happen
because otherwise you'd be calling on
Hamas to hand over the hostages and the
terrorists who took them because that's
how you get a ceasefire yeah I mean one
of the biggest blowups I had vat was
after that interview with that doctor
actually uh in which I'd already read
out some quotes from another member of
his group uh talking about LGBT filth
feminist filth really horrible
homophobic misogynist stuff which this
guy had been caught saying uh and and
the doctor is the leader of the UK arms
as one of his one of his people and then
he talked about people who want now to
women in particular who want now to
become Muslim I said what to live under
oppression and what I meant was the
oppression that had been spouted by this
guy
you know I'm not remotely anti-muslim
I'm not remotely anti-islam I led the
media campaign in this country against
the Iraq War for example I led the
defense of Qatar for its right to have
the World Cup and Expos a lot of Western
hypocrisy about the Chris and so on so I
really am not remotely anti-muslim I was
talking about the kind of interpretation
of Islam and Muslim world that members
of that group espouse which is vile
against women so if if you want them to
come into that world it is oppressive um
but it was interesting to me to watch
the Ferocious explosion on social media
which fall no relation to the context of
why I said what I
said if if I may uh I've been in this
for a long time I was 21 years old when
911 happened I Muslim American college
student and let me just if I may explain
to your viewers the double standard that
the rest of us feel just very quickly
Muslims are asked for the past 20 years
to condemn violent acts done by violent
people we've never met when I came on
your show last time you remember that it
was a Nutty guest who accused me of
being Hamas simply because I'm Muslim
and I had to condemn every single
violent extremist organization that's a
double standard that never happens to
any other group and I hope it doesn't
happen to any other group the second
thing is the most extreme violent
members of our quotequote community are
used to define us the most extreme
violent repris reprehensible people are
used to define the religion of 1.8
billion people that does not happen to
other other groups right imagine if I
said all white people are defined by the
KKK or Donald Trump and each and every
single time you're on TV I'm asking you
what do you say about these white
nationalist groups what do you say about
Donald Trump aren't you ashamed have you
condemned them you're like why are you
asking me and most of my friends aren't
like this and finally the warning the
warning I want to give the warning I
want to give here is you and I pierce
had the foresight to see the devastation
of the war and Terror you and I were the
ones 20 years ago who were against it
for those who are watching especially in
the UK learn from the American mistakes
when you use fear and anger and rage to
create domestic foreign policies it
leads to extremism it leads to divisions
we had a war against Iraq and
Afghanistan we had a quagmire we had
people being deported we had a chilling
effect we had a trust deficit between
law enforcement and American Muslim
communities we had to rise in hate
crimes learn from our mistakes and don't
let the worst of you and your worst
fears contaminate what you have in a in
UK which is a multi-racial soci you
still have hope vck thank you very much
indeed for joining me especially at late
notice as it was today we appreciate it
Constantine always great to have you on
I com I commend that film you've made
it's very enlightening people can go see
it on the trigonometry uh website which
is well worth half an hour of your time
thank you both very
much well on S of next the US and UK
launch fresh strikes on hoties in Yemen
they say it's to deescalate tensions and
restore stability in Red Sea but are
they doing the exact opposite should the
West butt out the Middle East debating
that next
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online and
we on your smart
speaking criminals to using XL Bully
dogs as weapons to threaten others no
matter how well trained most dog owners
will tell you a dog can turn do you know
what I love about to today we do it all
sunak sella
scon I rather like David C and I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and Rich soon at the
other Zak starma is a about to help make
children even taller
now he go that's what's going to happen
if you vote
labor Long Live JK rling and her right
to stand up for women but you can only
pity those who despise her
straightforward Politics As someh now
dangerous the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil Kevin O
Sullivan is the worst presenter on talk
TV sitting on his
fat like brought to you by Steve KH the
mayor of London vought us with our own
money the the mayor's fireworks very
rarely meet anybody that says you know
the thing about London is it's got a
great mayor it's a deep Cal brilliant
Guy this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film stop creating
all of these funny little factions with
their funny little names the new
conservatives the ERG the common sense
research group the red wool red trouser
popcorn I mean popcorn what what is that
I just cannot see if Rich suak goes does
what David Frost what Lord Frost wants
him to do and go further to the right on
taxes and immigration that that would
turn around the what's predicted by this
poll in a landslide Donald Trump didn't
just win he obliterated this is a guy
facing nearly a 100 criminal charges and
yet all that's done is actually make him
more popular Trump is canny enough to
know that all publicity is good
publicity I don't want a president who's
been impeached if he's able to amb
Boozle you that's the way it up I did my
6 months I came back nobody would touch
me I put my head down and persisted and
carried on when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV
it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
[Music]
that welcome back to un sensitive us and
UK have Unleashed a series of joint
fresh air strikes against houti Targets
in Yemen the strikes targeted an
underground storage site missiles and
other military capabilities in a joint
statement they said their aim remains to
deescalate tensions and restore
stability in the Red Sea Richi sunak
went one step further calling it
self-defense we urge the hooes and those
who enable them to stop these illegal
and unacceptable
attacks but if necessary the United
Kingdom will not hesitate to respond
again in self-defense so is it
self-defense and arber Strikes doing
anything but de-escalating the situation
in the Middle East or escalated them
joining me now to discuss this is the
son of the IDF General mattity p who is
now a Palestinian activist M ped and
yemeni journalist Lui Ahmed or welcome
to both of you um let me start with you
uh
m to me it seems pretty straightforward
you've got a a bunch of hoties who are
firing Rockets to try and stop I think
it's nearly 15% of the World's Trade
maybe more coming through the Red Sea
and they have to be stopped don't
they well I thanks for having on the
show uh appears I I I would frame it
slightly differently I think what we're
seeing is is Yemen forces acting
responsibly in response to a genocide
taking place in Palestine uh and we've
seen over the last uh month or so excuse
me three months or so we've seen a
heightening of the genocide with the
tens of thousands of Palestinian
civilians being Mass what does that have
to do with the hooes in Yemen with all
respect well well the International
Community has to act if the
International Community does not act to
stop Israel nothing will and countries
around the world needs to act and I
think what the yemeni forces are doing
are the are one of the only uh
responsible actions that we've seen the
other one of course has been the South
Africans with a petition to the icj the
International Community cannot continue
to ignore what is happening in Palestine
a 75y old genocide and and apartheid
regime and when one country decides to
step up and do the responsible thing and
respond they're being bombed by the
Americans and the British responsible
what is responsible about firing firing
rockets at cargo ships coming through
the Red Sea what is responsible
that well what is responsible is first
of all they they the the blockade of the
bab mandab is an act of resistance is an
act to it's an act in response to the
lack of action the severe criminal lack
of action by the rest of the world think
that's what I of the genocide taking
place I would say I want to come to my
is the issue all right let me come to
L you can't take it out of context Fe
take it out of ignore the Palestinian
issue I think it's being deliberately
conf it's being deliberately conflated
the context because Iran wants people to
think that way let me let me bring in L
arm let me bring in please the other
guest L your view of what you just
heard yeah I think it's actually quite
insulting to say that what the huis are
doing are acting responsibly the huthis
took over Yemen nor Northern yen by
force they slaughtered people they
killed people it is a terrorist group
that acts with violence and does not
care about the emies ever since the
huthis took over Northern Yemen more
than 21 million yemenis are in need of
humanitarian Aid more than 10 million
yemeni children are starving so if they
if the huthis were to act responsibly
they would take care of their own people
they would take care of their own
starving population Yemen is the biggest
humanitarian crisis in the Middle East
and it's been perpetrated also by a war
with Saudi AR Arabia that happened
because they took over the northern part
of Yemen so the huis should mind their
own business and care about their own
people who live in famine the yenes do
not need another war and one of the
reasons that many people in the west are
supporting huis and supporting their
actions is because they they're just
looking for any hero to bomb Israel I
mean even if if Hitler was alive today
and he started bombing Israel they would
all call him a hero because they can
they blindly hate Israel and they cannot
see the nuances they and most of them
don't even know the slightest bit of the
huthis because the huthis are not a
country like he says they're a militia
they're a sect that took over the
northern part of Yemen they're not the
legitimate power in Yemen but they took
over the country by force so they don't
really have any legitimacy as a as an
internationally recognized government
and they're also act by Iran which is
trying to impose its power on the rest
of the Middle East and I mean I I need
not tell you about what Iran has been
doing in the Middle East for the past 20
30 years they've also assassinated all
of their secular leaders next month
they're assassinating fatimi who is a
human rights Advocate who has been
criticizing them so it's kind of
insulting to say that they're acting
responsibly just because they're
attacking I can't to be honest I've
heard both sides now I I just think the
idea it's responsible is for the Birds
it's utterly irresponsible it's
warmongering it's deliberately
inflammatory it's Iran's behest and
they're getting the bloody nose they
deserve from the US and UK but trying to
preserve nearly 15% of the World's Trade
from going down in the Red Sea uh I
can't think of anything more responsible
than the response that's coming their
way anyway thank you both very much
indeed I appreciate it and that's the
next it's the movie about female
empowerment and dismantling the
patriarchy so why have the leading
ladies of Barbie missed out on the major
Oscars nods and Ken has got one is it a
victory in the end for the patriarchy
debating
[Music]
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online we're on your smart speaker as
well you know what I love about to today
we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes wrong unexpected item
in bagging area I know are we only going
to be trusting sources like meta and
Google where is our unbiased news going
to come from Gram was president of the
Cambridge unit which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan about Twitter you
sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call a teror group is it
possible to have a
rational talk TV it's the only place
where you get the
truth this is talk
[Music]
TV welome back Barbie is the box office
smash of the Year grossing over a
billion pounds worldwide it's a movie
about female empowerment dismantling the
patriarchy you'd expect his star Margo
robbing director Greta to be
recognized at the Oscars but the leading
ladies missed out on being recognized as
best director or best actress in those
categories and St Ken played by Ryan
goling has got a nomination for best
supporting actor so the patriarchy wins
and Ken as the last laugh joining me now
to discuss this his out post Tomy Len
talk to a contributor po R Adrian and
podcaster and comedian James Bar Tommy I
got to say I did laugh out loud at
seeing that Ken gets the last laugh uh
the patriarchy
wins yeah again the people that are so
fired up about this I just find it so
interesting you know they want Hollywood
to be all about Dei diversity Equity
inclusion only certain people can be
nominated only certain people can win
because otherwise you're going to upset
the diversity quota and the quoti that
they need to hit in order for everything
to be acceptable Hollywood is eating its
own tail here and then it's unfair
because Margot and Greta were not
nominated America Ferrera nominated Ken
obviously nominated with Ryan Gosling
but they're mad that these two ladies
weren't nominated by the way other
female directors nominated so to me it's
much to do about nothing I liked the
Barbie film I didn't think it was
necessarily the most challenging role
for Margot Robbie to play a doll I
didn't think that that really took maybe
a lot outside of her normal life to
portray that character but Piers if we
want to talk about unfairness and the
patriarchy let's talk about biological
men competing against women in sports I
want to see Hollywood get fired up about
that one and how unfair the patriarchy
is there exactly right Tommy L
ridiculous I can see you twoo agreeing
what a ridiculous thing to just throw in
at the end of chat about Hollywood
that's insane also it's not about what
is um acceptable it's about what is des
deserved right and I'm sorry but Greta
go deserved to be nominated but I
thought the movie was awful I thought it
played up to every stereotypical
nonsense Barbie was brilliant all the
other Barbies are brilliant Kim was a
knucklehead and by the way the only
thing that works is extermination of the
patriarchy and let women rule the world
and they base it all they based it all
on this company supposedly had all men
in its boardroom turns out reality it's
Half Men half women the whole things
based on a lie honestly the worst thing
about this is that it's a huge SN for
Greta and it's like the Oscars looked at
Will Smith and went who can we slap in
the face this year well maybe it wasn't
that good a movie I didn't think it was
well B the bafs think that it is and and
frankly lots of people who have seen it
agree that it's a great movie I
appreciate you've obviously watched it
man mocking TSH well and we can see why
you didn't watch it and I think it's
interesting man's have a last laugh
interesting that you're focusing on the
patriarchy as if somehow you clearly
Miss missed the message that the movie
was trying to I got the message all men
are awful it's the same message we saw
when Gillette suddenly decided that all
men use their products are awful and
Harvey Weinstein look alikes unless they
can prove otherwise oh you're such a
victim aren't you victim we are a down
man go we know don't we that when we
talk about patriarchy the reality of
patriarchy is about for example the fact
that women are still not paid the same
as men we're looking at still you how
much made from on do you know how much
mango bar she also produced it through a
production company I last heard we're
talking north of 100 Mil you're doing
okay in Hollywood I mean we're not
talking about the exception to the rule
argument here P because we know that
that never wins but interestingly enough
no matter how much she earns she's still
not good enough get by the way I love
Margo Robbie I hated Barbie I think she
will win an Oscar for something else and
she'll deserve it great a girl very
talented wrote a movie bashing men and a
man's the one who gets Ned awful way to
I know but it's true but it's also true
I want to ask Tommy about another
oppressed man uh Prince Harry who went
to this extraordinary event in Hollywood
where he was declared a living legend of
Aviation and no one's quite sure why
what did you make of
this well I'll tell you as much as I
hate to say this Hollywood can have
Harry and Megan that's probably the only
place they're useful at this point
they're still living out their 15
minutes of f I think it's going to
dwindle but I would say Piers we should
just stop talking about them we should
stop shining the light on them and then
they will Scurry they will go away we
breathe life into them by giving them
attention they really have no Talent
they really have not much to offer so we
stop talking about them and I think
their light will dim even faster than
it's already going to by Nature I like
your thinking Tommy such an expert on
people that have no Talent wow and
actually I'm going to disagree with
Tommy on this one I want to hear about
Harry I want to hear about the good
things think a living want to hear about
the good things I want to hear about
Megan because it's important for us to
remember that he won his case it's
important for us to continue to push
that message that he and others others
who aren't as famous as Harry were able
to successfully shine a light on what
was wrong with the British press way
back when about important what's got to
do with the British then isn't Liv
Legend to blame for that's not why he
got the award actually got the award for
his Aviation
and he deserves that Aviation award
because he caused you quite a lot of
turbulence PE Morgan I don't mind what
turbulence he causes me he's a sick oh
you do he's a sick it RS you up sick
storm peers is affecting us all right
now the biggest Intruder into Royal
privacy of all time you know who it is
Prince Harry Prince Harry ultimate
hypocrisy he wrote a book literally
revealing conversations with his family
at the gravide of his grandfather it's
hard to
imagine
I think you're can't let go of him think
you think he's a living legend I think
he's a living conratulations going have
to leave it there Tommy always a
pleasure to get Common Sense from you
across the pond if only it was shared on
my two friends to my left well maybe you
should move to America they love you
there I love America I was just there
for three and a half weeks loved it
because they understand Common Sense
better than you two clowns anyway thank
you both very much indeed coming next
we're going to talk to the fake Prince
uh who posed for a selfie with another
fake Prince
um yeah Prince Mario Max joins me live
next about his encounter with a living
legend I wonder if you felt the same
[Music]
way we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and we're on your smart
speaking criminals to using XL Bully
dogs as weapons to threaten others no
matter how well trained most dog owners
will tell you a dog can turn you know
what I love about today we do it all
sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the
other saki starma is about to help make
children even taller
now go that's what's going to happen if
you vote labor
Long Live JK Rowling and her right to
stand up for women we can only pity
those who despise her straightforward
Politics as somehow
dangerous the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil Kevin O
Sullivan is the worst presenter on talk
TV sitting on on his
fat was like brought to you by Steve KH
the mayor of London bought us with our
own money the the mayor's fireworks very
rarely meet anybody that says you know
the thing about London is he got a great
mayor he's a deep charm brilliant
Guy this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film stop creating
all of these funny little factions with
their funny little names the new
conservatives the ERG the common sense
research group the red wool red trouser
popcorn I mean popcorn what what is that
I just cannot see if Rishi suak goes
does what David Frost what Lord Frost
wants him to do and go further to the
right on taxes and immigration that that
would turn around the what's predicted
by this poll in a landslide Donald Trump
didn't just win he obliterated this is a
guy facing nearly a 100 criminal charges
and yet all that's done is actually make
him more popular Trump is canny enough
to know that all publicity is good
publicity I don't want a president who's
been impeached if he's able to bamboozle
you that's the way it come but did my 6
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down and persisted and
carried on when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV
it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that welcome back to on I'm joined Now
by Prince Mario Max uh who was a guy we
saw a picture with Prince Harry at the
living legend award welcome to the show
do you perceive Prince Harry to be a
living legend of
Aviation Pier first of all thank you for
having me and I'm a real journalist
since 30 years guess what I make a
living on in working in the field in the
same industry and secondly I'm a real
Prince because my dad Prince vemer has a
Danish Royal mother and was actually
knowing Queen Elizabeth and it was the
first time for me to meet her grandson
my Dad loved Queen Elizabeth he to took
pictures of her why you called the F why
you called the fake Prince then it's not
one guy is saying that which is a neik
German who elevates himself to say I am
the big shamb Lipper we are all the same
in Germany every shambu glipper prince
is just a regular guy I'm a working guy
in America and this guy makes himself
pushy on the press and hates and Bullies
us since decades my dad hated him and
now he's jumping the Harry and Max
picture to put himself in the Press
co-piloting us we just had a nice talk I
said my dad loved your grandmother they
took pictures together my dad was a
court photographer in Denmark at his
cousin the Danish Queen and I'm so happy
to meet you I've never met you and that
was all and he said glad and he spoke
about his award and by the way this
award it's so important I'm attending
since years the lips family that runs at
a friends of mine we're taking vacations
together so this lips family has all
these people in these living legend
Awards and the ones who decide who gets
these awards are the Living Legends
themselves and I called them yesterday
and I said why Prince Harry and they
said hey Prince Mario Max read in the
program and it will tell you air
controller helicopter pilot that's how
he was pitched by the fellow aviators
that's let me jump in that's not why he
won the award he won the award cuz they
wanted to get a member of the British
royal family to the event so they gave
him an award there are t of thousands of
helicopter Pilots people have done his
job all over the world
anyway a huge personality so run out a
time I'm going to have to leave it
Prince great to talk to you that's it
from me whatever you're up to keep it
[Music]
uncensored
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit haries
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn do you know what I love
about talk today we do it all sunak
sella scon
I rather like David Cameron I don't sort
of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
done through normalizing relations with
Saudi Arabia the Tories love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sinak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police of pro Palestine that is just not
right you swear an o in the police to
act without fear or favor the co inquiry
seems to have turned into a sort of
pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for Sadi Khan we're not stopping until
you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking liit if you're walking towards
me and you're a vegan should have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC Mouse
man MC man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house for of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film